good to see you they traveled from all
over the world to find answers eight
years after the lives of their loved
ones ended abruptly in the sky over
Ukraine more than 10 different
nationalities were on board Malaysian
Airlines flight mh17
196 of the 298 victims were Dutch the
plane departed from schipple to Kuala
Lumpur when it was downed over a war
zone in eastern Ukraine the bodies of
those on board and debris from the plane
fell in a field near the village of
kabove
the Court ruled that there was no doubt
that the plane was shut down with an
anti-aircraft book missile brought in
from Russia and fired from a field
controlled by pro-russian separatists
two former Russian Intelligence Officers
and one Ukrainian separatist Commander
are held responsible for transporting
the missile
qualifications
the court considered proven that the
suspects conspired to purposefully and
illegally bring down a plane knowing to
cause mortal danger Anton cotta lost his
eldest son daughter-in-law and
six-year-old grandson ramco traveling to
Bali for vacation damko's backpack was
all that came home intact for us is it
very important to show the world to show
the
the Russians
see what you have done
you've taken the life of a six-year-old
child
and now we are eight years further or
and all that I ask myself
what have they missed all these eight
years in the past two and a half years
Carter attended more than 65 Court
hearings fulfilling a promise he made to
his dad's son to find the truth the
judge stressed how immense the suffering
of the relatives here has been for the
past eight years with the bodies of
their loved ones scattered in a field in
eastern Ukraine some for weeks but even
though those convicted have not attended
the trial they feel that justice has
been done there was water in my eyes
what am I
well it's unbelievable law experts say
the verdict was groundbreaking because
For the First Time a Court ruled that
Russia controlled armed and financed the
separatist rebels of the donets People's
Republic in eastern Ukraine this is a
very important ruling even though this
case was not about Russia the court was
very clear that it was about Russia it
was Russia that had overall control over
the DPR forces the book came from Russia
couldn't have been done without Russia
knowing it Russia has always denied any
involvement to Russian foreign Ministry
has called The Verdict scandalous saying
that throughout the trial the court was
under unprecedented pressure to impose a
politically motivated outcome
prosecutors and the three convicted men
have two weeks to decide to appeal the
verdict stepfather Al Jazeera skipol